the roughneck from Columbus Ohio has
given up gold for glory with famous
racing driver far behind him edward
vernon rickenbacker is now in france
as captain eddie of the 94th Air Squadron
and enlistee he's made chauffeur to Billy
Mitchell famed aviator then stalks
Mitchell into letting him transfer to
Air Corps after 17 days of training he's
given commissioned wings and new plane
here's how Eddie looked in French skies as
he prowled for German fools April 29th 1918
he shot down his first ship then blasted 20
more to become first flier of World War one
for his achievements as flying ace and his
captain and Commander of 94th air squadron
Rickenbacker Center is awarded medal of
honor by general Girard Fame he wins in
France precedes him to America at war's
end he's among nation's greatest heroes
America's flying aids races Rickenbacker
is merely a threshold to fame and fortune
at home in 1924 thousands cheer as Eddie
completes first flight of mayo from coast
to coast now pursuing Aviation's peacetime enemies
time distance and red ink captain Rickenbacker is
fast becoming ace of commercial flying he's now
married to Adelaide Durant has tried automobile
business failed because Rickenbacker car was
too advanced four times so it's back to work
with wings in 1928 at Camden New Jersey Airport
Rickenbacker is that controlled of what is then
largest airplane ever built it's another a happy
landing for captain Eddie another Rickenbacker
contribution to advance in aviation as national
and worldwide industry then in 1930 he visits
Washington and paid call at the White House for
President Herbert Hoover Awards him this nation's
highest medal yes to the many honors already
accorded him for his achievement as pilot in
peace and war edward vernon rickenbacker
is given the Congressional Medal of Honor
then he asked for and his given job in World
War two just 16 months after Airlines crack up
near Atlanta in which he nearly died he's off
on tour of our Pacific air bases at special
envoy of his friend and Air Force general HAP
Arnold and as he heads for Hawaii fate once
again sends him headlong into danger and another
scrape with death is just hours in the future
for 22 days he and his companions were lost
so Navy searched specific waters for them
they were given up for lost until one day
their rubber raft is spotted by accident
flown back to safety Rickenbacker and his
companions were weak and worn one man is
dead and Rickenbacker himself is wasted by
hunger burned by cruel Pacific Sun blistered
by wind and biting saltwater aching for
more than three weeks of confinement in
a tiny rubber raft but he can still
show the famous Rickenbacker smile
few weeks later he's back on job and in
1948 as president and general manager of
Eastern Airlines he officiates at historic
ceremonies of company he heads and leads
well captain any rickenbacker who shut
them down in 1918 keeps them flying today